hey 42 here Frank Dux was a legendary
fighter when he was a teenager he was
taken under the wing of a master named
Senzo Tiger Tanaka and trained in the
ancient art of ninjitsu Senzo was a
world-famous teacher and descendant of
40 generations of warriors taking to the
art very quickly Dux became sin Zoe's
greatest pupil but his master was an old
man and after teaching docks all of his
knowledge he passed away making only one
request of dogs before he did he must
compete in the kumite and become the
first Westerner ever to win the trophy
the kumite was a near mythical
no-holds-barred 60 round
single-elimination martial arts
tournament it had been heard of spoken
about but rarely had anyone actually
ever seen it it was supposedly a
long-standing tournament where the
greatest martial artists from all over
the world came and fought to their death
but it was only held once every five
years so dogs have to wait during this
time he entered the Marines and was
awarded the Medal of Honor for covert
operations he undertook in Southeast
Asia it was during this time that dogs
gained black belts in Taekwondo and
became a master of knife fighting but in
1975 he heard a whisper something
shocking the kumite had been announced
and his chance to fulfill his late
masters died anguish had come true going
AWOL from the military Dux travels to
the Bahamas sort out the tournament and
began the fight to honor his master's
legacy and that he did because Ducks
became the first-ever Westerner to win
the tournament but not only that he
scored 56 consecutive knockouts one of
which was incredibly in Siro point one
two seconds both feats were world
records because of this incredible
performance Dux was deems the honor of
being the first person to be allowed to
publicly speak about the kumite after
this Dux returned to the army and began
undertaking
covert ops both for the military and the
CIA playing a role in operations in
Central America during the 1980s he also
began forming his own martial art
schools where he could pass on the
knowledge he had learned from his own
masters it was during this time that his
incredible story became more widely
known and was even the basis for the
jean-claude Van Damme movie bloodsport
for which Dux was hired to be the fight
coordinator the film was a huge
box-office success an instant cult
classic massively increasing Frank Dux
his notoriety which off the back of he
created his own martial arts dojos and
even bizarrely being offered $25,000 to
kill Steven Seagal of all people through
listening to this astonishing man story
it would be unsurprising if you forced
him to be the greatest warrior who ever
lived but all of these events and
achievements aren't the most astonishing
or even most interesting detail of his
life the most incredible thing about
Frank Dux is that it's all complete
[ __ ] he made it all up it was all a
lie presumably made up by dogs to build
his own reputation and profit from it a
lie believed by so many that it made its
way to Hollywood but the truth is that
there's no record of a Senzo Tanaka ever
existing Dux is only military records
say that he fell off a truck and never
left San Diego and the one supposed
witness to Dux his incredible life story
later revealed he had been coached by
docks on what he should verify Dux was
eventually entirely exposed by the Los
Angeles Times the world of martial arts
is incredibly dangerous not just because
its central principle is to teach you
how to hurt people and protect yourself
from harm but also because there is an
ironic cap 22 inherent within most
martial arts disciplines what if the
martial art you're learning cannot
actually
- and your very faith in it exposes you
to more danger with martial arts having
faith that your teachings can actually
defend you during a fight can be a
matter of life or death if you believe
one plus one equals free you'll probably
struggle with maths and be the victim of
ridicule but if you believe you know how
to stop a knife with a self-defense
technique and it proves to fail you
could end up very very dead
whereas most incorrect beliefs puts you
at odds with others incorrect martial
arts beliefs put you straight on track
from an ass-kicking or abettor simorgh
luckily the days of martial arts here
say in which figures like Frank Dux
thrived is rapidly becoming a thing of
the past
and there is one major reason why the
emergence of MMA although MMA or mixed
martial arts in some format has existed
since ancient Greece in recent decades
it has grown hugely in popularity to the
point where fighters like Conor McGregor
and Ronda Rousey are household names and
the industry brings in hundreds of
millions each year and its popularity is
easy to explain
whereas boxing or judo will put two
practitioners of the same fighting style
against one another
MMA pits two fighters of just about any
fighting style imaginable against one or
another the result is that it has become
an incredibly fertile ground for see
which martial arts work and those that
absolutely do not which in a data
starved field like martial arts is a
godsend for being able to assess the
real-world effectiveness of each unique
discipline
striking arts such as boxing and
kickboxing hands takedown and Submission
arts such as judo Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
[ __ ] and wrestling have all proven to
be extremely effective with one caveat
they are each most effective against
certain foes that use certain styles a
boxer might be able to knock out a
master wrestler but if the
that gets him on the ground the box is
going to be in big trouble
and vice versa John Jones and habib
Norma Khmer DAF are a testament to this
ability to fuse the proven effective
styles under dominates their opponents
with them whilst they each may
specialize in a certain discipline they
are both highly skilled at picking the
right tools from their toolkit when the
moment calls
thus MMA has taught the world to
revealing aspects of martial arts the
first is that one art is probably not
entirely effective on its own the second
is that a fighter must be able to fight
at multiple proximities and heights a
distance on a close on their feet in the
clinch in the takedown and on the floor
ignore any one of these areas of
discipline in your opponent will not
hesitate to take advantage of it for
years martial artists only fought
against practitioners of their own
singular discipline meaning that martial
arts were largely designed to provide
techniques for attacking and defending
against only that very same discipline
this left martial arts with limited
avenues for evolution as they weren't
being tested for their actual real-world
versatility which is like only ever
receiving feedback on your cooking from
your own family whereas the rest of the
culinary world would probably tear it
apart this meant that when some martial
arts made their debut in MMA they were
very quickly dispatched and their gaping
weaknesses torn wide apart sumo
wrestling for instance was met with a
quick reality check when Royce Gracie
dismantled Akebono Tara although an
expert sumo wrestler and by far the
larger man Akebono was easily defeated
and Gracie demonstrated how effectively
Brazilian jiu-jitsu can control a man on
the ground and defeat him this
highlights an immediate question what
actually makes a martial art world well
the most effective acid test would be
this does it consistently perform
against a completely uncooperative fully
resisting aggressive
Poland's if the answer is no be
extremely skeptical about any claims
made as to its capabilities
another concern highlighted by Bruce Lee
was whether a martial art actually arms
a practitioner with tools and teaches
them how and when to use them
comparing Western boxing to Tai Chi he
said a boxer when they concentrate on
their two hands they forget how
amateurish they are and they do their
thing
whereas those guys out there referring
to Tai Chi they haven't decided what
they're going to use the minute they
contact they don't know what the hell
they're going to use he expanded on this
to describe effective fighting gas if
you can move with your tools for many
angle then you can adapt to whatever the
object is in front of you the clumsier
the more limited the objects the easier
for you to punch on it that's what it
amounts to this brings us to ineffective
martial arts of which there are many now
whilst these martial arts have a place
in the world and are probably fine for
developing discipline character and
fitness as well as being extremely
effective when used against
practitioners of their own style they're
generally not effective at actual self
defense or attack for that matter arts
like sumo Wing Chun Tai Chi capoeira and
kung fu have all had troubled
reputations at proving their
effectiveness and aside from less
mystical branches of kung fu most of
them have little to no reputation in MMA
one Chinese MMA fighter Xue Zedong was
so frustrated with the claims of many of
these martial arts particularly eastern
ones that he proceeded to challenge the
so-called masters amongst many victories
he defeated a kung fu master who
supposes supernatural powers in twenty
seconds flat under Wing Chun master in
one minute 48 seconds into the first
round even though the man was 26 and a
half pounds heavier whilst experts in
their art neva was capable of even
remote
defending themselves against a capable
fully resisting aggressive opponent
sadly for zoo the result was the Chinese
Communist Party docking his social
credit score so much that he couldn't
afford basic living or travel costs and
he was publicly harassed assaulted and
barred from his own gym this also
highlights a key issue that many
ineffective martial arts face poor
sparring technique is continually
practiced against a compliant non
resisting opponent meaning that you and
the technique itself are woefully
ill-equipped for a real-world
confrontation this extends to so-called
self-defence martial arts like Krav Maga
whilst these techniques have been
designed by the military to work in
combat zones they also rely on
incredibly dangerous attacks such as AI
couching attacking an opponent in the
scrotum under disarming them of a knife
only to stab them with it in the heart
while STIs may be effective there is no
way for you to properly train such
techniques in sparring with a resisting
opponent without maiming or killing them
to say nothing of the fact that your
sparring partner would always have to be
very compliant for you to even pull off
these maneuvers at non dangerous speeds
these martial arts also beg the question
what's the actual point of defending
yourself if you end up lining yourself
in prison on manslaughter or GBH charges
what's effective in a life-or-death
battlefield scenario isn't very
necessary for everyday life in 99% of
scenarios simply having the fitness and
motivation to run away would probably be
far more effective and intelligent
another point worth mentioning is that
there is a lot more to fighting itself
than just knowing techniques your
courage physical size fitness and
experience have far more bearing on the
actual result of the confrontation than
the knowledge of technique you might
know how to perform an eye gouge but
let's see you do that against a big
aggressive man who's fought and won
hundreds of pub scraps during his life
but sure
perhaps you might be able to pull it off
as he uppercuts you into the middle of
next week
but beyond ineffective martial-arts
techniques there are some martial arts
that are just out and out they so fake
in fact that they border on hilarious
lunacy the deeper you go into the world
of martial arts the stranger things
become but few things are more bizarre
than claims of no touch knockouts by
harnessing Chi powers and using psychic
manipulation one martial art called
Balinese yellow bamboo claims to blast
people with got charged beams of Chi as
a method of self-defence guy is running
at you with a meat cleaver no worries
just blast him with Chi naturally when
put to the test by real trained fighters
the yellow bamboo fighters fails to
deploy the necessary Chi to stop them
Yanagi ryuken an Aikido master and
pioneer of daito-ryu Aikido made
repeated claims that he could physically
manipulate his environments and knock
out his opponents without touching them
however when confronted by journalist
and fighter eric ora Tsuyoshi
he was rapidly dispatched and left badly
bleeding later claiming his defeat was
due to illness likewise georges Dillman
a controversial martial arts figure
known for his no touch knockout cheap
power described a nervous failure to
fall victim to his technique by saying
they had put their tongue in the wrong
position and that they were a
non-believer but why do these bizarre
techniques practiced by entire dojos of
students appeal to so many and why do
they seem to work when the master
practices them on his students and how
on earth do these masters delude
themselves that they work well the
psychology of no-touch knockouts has a
lot to do with Dillman's comments on
being a non-believer it turns out if
you're a believer you likely will be
knocked down by these no-touch attacks
in fact Dillman has
convinced dozens of students that he can
knock them down and out without ever
touching them it's remarkably similar to
techniques employed by gangs religions
and cults that is vulnerable people are
offered safety and the sense of
belonging the more they invest their
lives into the group the more they
double down on their belief it becomes
part of their identity this leads to a
complete lack of questioning of the
master under the tradition an increasing
reliance on the group and its training
an increased alienation from real-life
moral social and dress codes are in
force and rival groups are talked about
like their enemies perhaps most
interesting of all is that when people
in these groups are confronted with a
reality that disproves the group's
premise they don't renounce it they
simply double down on their beliefs this
results in two things one the fake
martial arts practitioner becomes
completely compliant to the nonsense
techniques and lets himself get flung
around by psychic powers and to the
master comes to believe his own nonsense
and as is the case of Yanagi ryokan
living out a power fantasy kept alive by
vulnerable people who are easily
manipulated until the ends of having a
brutal reunion with reality these
masters are no more than con men who got
fooled by their own con an interesting
paper by Gillian Russell talks about
this and she boils it all down to a
concept she calls epistemic viciousness
meaning the possession of vices that
makes one badass acquiring true beliefs
or gives one a tendency to form false
ones this inclination towards epistemic
viciousness is rife in the martial arts
world because of their closed mindedness
reliance on tradition and failure to
adequately confront reality this goes
not just for fake martial arts but the
ineffective ones I mentioned earlier is
a tai chi or Krav Maga expert with no
real-world experience in fighting
actually qualified to defend himself let
alone teach others to and is teaching
governs a non effective defense
technique
surely dangerous to illustrate epistemic
viciousness she uses the example of her
11 year old self being taught by her
karate master that if she trained a
straight punch for three years she could
kill a bull with a single strike
which is obviously ludicrous and would
probably result in her vicious mauling
which brings me to my next point
fake martial arts are incredibly
dangerous and the fake martial artists
who creates them even more so
John Timothy kyun otherwise known as
count Dante created the dim Mac or death
torch fighting style and peddled it to
unsuspecting teenagers in comic book
Magazine adverts who didn't know any
better he became so successful and so
lost within his own fantasy that he
would instigate dojo Wars one of which
led to the murder of his students
another man Raphael Tora was a supposed
BJJ expert who was initially extremely
famous and in the world of mixed martial
arts however when he actually
participated in a real fight that he
fought for some reason he could win he
was quickly dispatched off and shown to
have little skill in BJJ in fact it
wasn't till years later that he pulled
off a real rear naked choke against a
truly resisting opponent when he
murdered his lovers husband or consider
actor Mickey Rourke whose claims to
being a former boxer were backed up by a
record that couldn't be found on an
opponent who claims to have been paid to
take a dive whilst not being a danger to
others why he'd go to such lengths to
lie about being a fighter and then
endanger himself by doing so is beyond
anyone however I don't want to end this
video on a dour notes of dangerous
practices and deceptive martial arts
masters instead I'd like you to take
from this one clear lesson not just for
martial arts but for life in general
never take anything as proven when you
haven't seen evidence of it being proven
time and time again
never trust a master who claims to know
everything but never actually backs it
up with
evidence and always questioned the
beliefs that have been driven into your
head by others that is unless it's me
who's put them there in which case you
should believe and serve unquestioningly
thanks for watching if you enjoyed this
video then please consider supporting me
on patreon because it really helps me to
continue to make these videos the links
in the description below also if you'd
like to get your hands on a first
edition signed a copy of my new book
stick of liken it's a thousand years of
bizarre history from Britain and beyond
then head on over to unbound publishing
the links in the description and
pre-order yours today thank you